c'est un retournement de conjoncture
comment redoutent les entreprises en
pleine crise du covid récif Pharma monte
avait été choisi par l'américain moderne
à pour conditionner ses vaccins cocorico
l'état mettez même la main à la poche
pour doper la production deux ans après
le covid n'est plus qu'il était et les
commandes ont stoppé net un tiers des
effectifs vont donc être supprimés les
précisions de Clémence dosc
la nouvelle est tombée ce mercredi un
accord de rupture conventionnelle
collective a été signée entre la
direction de recypharm à monts et les
syndicats après un passage en activité
partielle en décembre dernier ce sont
maintenant 95 départ volontaires qui
sont programmés le site de
conditionnement stérile avait été choisi
en 2021 pour la production du vaccin
anti covid de l'américain moderna deux
ans plus tard les commandes ont cessé il
faut se remettre dans une dans un
contexte de la pandémie à l'époque nous
avons recruté pour nous aider à répondre
à la crise sanitaire dans lequel le pays
se trouvait il est très très difficile
dans ce genre de situation de pouvoir
prévoir voilà le contexte a maintenant
énormément changé 70 millions de dos
sont sortis entre 2021 et 2022 une
centaine d'embauches avaient alors été
réalisé et une une ligne devait voir le
jour un choix à double tranchant car
aujourd'hui il faut accompagner les
salariés pour les réorienter il faut a
été très dur dans la négociation
notamment pour accompagner au mieux les
salariés à en proposant de la formation
un congé de mobilité pour pour les
accompagner durant la sortie de
l'entreprise on a même imposé un cabinet
de reclassement local pour vraiment
privilégier une reprise locale sur le
pour le l'emploi les modalités des
départs seront étayées auprès des
salariés dans les jours à venir les
volontaires partiront dès le mois de
juin les effectifs du site repasseront
ainsi de 320 à 225 personnes